[Music]
in Karma's a [ __ ] news oh yeah now
where she's nice Viet coffee best coffee
it is Cafe Santa is one of the best you
gotta do the end like that
the serial killer accidentally killed
himself in jail during a strange solo 60
SEC's I bet your units I bet used
Tolkien himself and jacking off but then
like the choke went to out of control
and then he hung my second he was [ __ ]
all teeth too huh
he stole a power drill from the [ __ ]
mechanic area of the of the jail and he
tried to drill his [ __ ] and punctured
his [ __ ] intestines he gets off with
stinking [ __ ] and his belly button hole
I know I'm right [ __ ] I can't I don't
know it yes I think we exhausted all of
our options
she's here maybe he found a really high
tightrope and he's trying to jack off
while being on the tightrope so he can
like like see if he can come while he's
scared and he fell off of it oh maybe he
stuck his dick into something no I mean
you guys were still guessing oh I know
what he was doing he had boiling hot
water and he dipped his nuts in it so
that when he jacks off he wants to shoot
melted come like even streaming like
that the lower the viscosity of the come
but when they're happy he fell in the
pot and he bawled himself yeah the most
creative man I've ever that creative
know what I ended up doing was that he
got the cord from his lamp
what like stripped the cord wounded
around his nipple
he stuck the power socket oh he wanted
that he electrocuted himself he elected
that he exceed our imagination never
happened in the history of Jacob you
want to told me there's a lap in his
room
yeah why do they have you lectricity
this is in the u.s. though right
no this isn't really nicer privileges
well they get electricity and she had a
bedside table lamp
you know the jails in some European
countries look like our hotels I was
like a rug and a vacuum and they really
like try to change people and help them
that's good he was a German serial
killer who murdered five female
hitchhikers their Autobahn dope ass
[ __ ] name is actually action
strangler that's what he didn't stink ah
I like guten autumn is so much better he
was committing murders between 1983 and
1990 he wasn't discovered until eighteen
years after his last murder in 2008
sucks cuz he thought he got away the
whole time in the way he said it took
that long I don't put myself in his
shoes and I'm like yes I'm safe and then
randomly someone [ __ ] randomly someone
comes and arrests you look what the [ __ ]
a dog got away with encoded by for 18
years yeah it's no sympathy for me now
we're about statute of limitations so he
got me [ __ ] are you arguing right now
you know what are you are you know what
he watching movie you put yourself and
the main guys shoes that's what I always
do in the news so when it took about a
minute the bad guy I put myself in his
shoes and then I pull myself back out
like that's wrong dude did he just take
a blonde break
he's like I'm barred so in 2007 he was
arrested because he was stealing scrap
metal and when he was arrested he
voluntarily gave a DNA sample and that's
when they connected him to these oh he
was like you guys are so stupid I'm
bored now probably here I'll throw you a
bone sauerkraut string
one of his victims was just 15 years old
oh that's [ __ ] up see this that's the
part when I pull myself out gosh is too
[ __ ] up he raped three of the five
yeah I'm way out
I'm well so this all there is rape
involved too that's how he got any time
I hear a guy did like killing a girl I
automatically assume it's reversed
there's sexy times going on here yeah
one-way sex times yeah Oh what I think
serial killer I just think of a slasher
I don't think of a guy that jacks where
he kills no so that's why this whole
thing the way he died was kind of ironic
because he would tie up these women and
so he died by tying up the South
Australia so he died as a result of
heart failure
from the electric crack two years old
damn god damn he looks like a gentleman
[ __ ] this gentle really yes murder its
eyeball look like a volleyball coach
yeah United mean who could help me like
his bags look heavy dude like testicle
bags yeah I think that's that guy yeah
oh that should look heavy that will look
like he hasn't slept in days dude
looking like a wide-body shoot eyeball I
mean eyelids like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
creep I'm glad he's like the [ __ ]
bratwurst brawlers oh [ __ ] the bratwurst
no bratwurst butcher all bratwurst
Roberts butcher yeah oh no I just we're
just making out serial killer named John
I don't know anything else German what
else is German Pierre client is a client
year he's the he's the [ __ ] he's the
Alpine he's the Alpine killer priceless
how - fixing yeah he's [ __ ] angry ale
ok they drink ale in in the German lands
they drink all kinds all kinds of okay
angry ale we were on the Autobahn and
you just see cars going oh really
did you did you guys get to drive fast
we're in a bus did you tell them the
gold we could know how many lanes is the
Autobahn I guess it's too late so then
there's some cars that pass you yes and
you like you know like when you even
hear like you know what the slow in the
fast lane is so everyone knows to move
off to this end you just see cars of war
but what if there's two supercars going
as fast as possible and then one decides
to pass your bus and then they play
chicken what happens then I will crash
at the Autobahn driving really fast is
frightening though like just like a
small little jitter in your wheel yeah
yeah what's the what's the fastest
you'll go before it's just like when I
was driving the Tesla from Sacramento
back to LA and the everybody was
sleeping and I don't know I have met
foot it's all so tired I was more like a
good like hundred and ten mmm and then I
only knew because I will move a little
bit and they kind of [ __ ] the part I was
like oh [ __ ] like if the car is good
like man it's hard to tell how fast it
is sometimes I must be demon but I'm not
a speed demon in terms of like just like
gunning it I like going like you like
weaving yeah probably but I'm just
saying between the two I don't like just
going to drag racer yeah you know it's
really fun you don't even need a go like
50 miles per hour you probably go about
30 to 40 but if you have a windy road on
a cliff or the mountain
last before shape and if there's like
you could drift that's even more crazy
she's crazy because she doesn't want to
drive she wants to sit in the passenger
side that's [ __ ] crazy yeah I'd
rather sit in paddle trust you yeah
that's crazy right
that's an adrenaline junkie for sure if
you want skydiving you have to pull your
own shoot you do I [ __ ] that I wanted to
do that but it scares me more than
having someone else pull it [ __ ] no it
is pretty scary though cuz there's a
there's like a specific time like a halt
I got 12,000 I think oh I get what you
mean it's like someone else is gonna
push the limit harder than you so if you
were in a car with a pro driver you know
that thing I don't they still have it
but at Magic Mountain is this big-ass
Ark and then you take you to the top and
then you pull the string and then it you
go for I remember that's it so I didn't
pull a stream yeah so I did yeah so I
did that and they go three two one fly
so there's three of you you can do that
one where you're facedown
yeah and it looks like you're about to
[ __ ] eat the ground then I had to
pull the string I was like three two one
pool what if you don't pull well they
probably bring you down okay you ruin
your everybody oh there's always that
one yeah young always down to race we
always bring a Stewart Randy what are we
always race we always race I'll kill it
in my car though yeah that's not fair
well I weave way better than you do so
it's pretty close Mart sheets you'll go
against traffic in shape oh my god just
to win [ __ ] that I'm on board against
traffic yeah I'm Chinese dude dude no
that's an apart yeah like on the grass
yeah like he got when your car when your
truck was lifted and you just drove onto
the [ __ ] cars are scary man remember
when Frank
he had his supervisors game and then I
got it and he drove he [ __ ] boy Supra
that thing was crazy
he's [ __ ] gone man never been so
scared of my [ __ ] life yeah cuz like
it he was like are you ready
I like sure Oh
lift my head off the ceiling god damn it
that's you I think his Carla's a
subscriber abandon that she does not
find that she was frightening us out
that she was like I think I like ya
thousand horsepower assumptions I bet
allude to warp speed like it was just in
a neighborhood like a straightaway oh no
and the [ __ ] road is really really
tight yeah he he he was trying to invite
me to go to these days where they they
block off like an airstrip so he's
racing rambles and stuff he sees
destroyed Lambos on Ferraris there's
only like one Lambo that he's never beat
but everyone else you just destroys them
because it's it's so long that after you
hit like 180 or whatever you still can
slow down is it a drag racing place it's
a quarter mile eighth it's an airstrip
what if I Supra even though I wouldn't
dress oh it's really is really long
those are really expensive oh is it that
retired [ __ ] Airport like Riverside
Airport or one of those places um I
don't know I'm not too sure cuz I saw
some [ __ ] they do road racing there they
set up cones and stuff and then all
these [ __ ] ballers come and their
trucks they have like there's so many
[ __ ] rich people it's just it's
mind-blowing how much money people have
they'll have a straight-up trailer with
just multiple cars multiple yeah and
then they'll bring that it is not only
just one Ferrari like they got to and
then or whatever you know and then
they're just they're just going and
[ __ ] turning and twisting and in
dudes will come in with Miatas and [ __ ]
and all kinds of cars yeah I'm gonna be
surprised if the Ferrari dealership or
whatever like they put on it I think cuz
for my car like you're invited to that
and you can just drive a bunch of
beamers the BMW one is really fun yeah
but can you go hard are you allowed to
go hard they have a driver with you but
it's not that hard yeah it's provide
every one of those invite it all the
time you never gone no I think it just
doesn't work out with my spec you should
do it it's fun I want to do the Porsche
one I don't even have a porch anymore
but I want do the Porsche one you can go
to their Porsche experience I think they
have like a whole track it it's a free
no I think I think you've you don't have
a porch probably gotta pay for it but
this is one where it's like a big puddle
of water oh it's a skinny guy skip me
yeah I want to do that one too
[Music]